hello everybody hi oh thank you thank
you big warm welcome to everybody who's
here in person and a big shout out to
everyone watching online hi mom this is
what's new in Android wear 2.0 I'm Dan
Coulomb Jean I'm the tech lead for
system UI on Android wear and I'm Brett
Leiter I'm the design lead for Android
wear and so for Android wear 2.0 we want
to redefine what it means to be a great
useful SmartWatch when we want to enable
you developers to build great
experiences for it for users and so to
talk about what's new in Android wear
we're actually going to reflect back a
little bit on the things we've learned
over the last two years since Android
wear it came out so when Android wear
first came out it was very much tethered
to the phone and this was a great
solution two years ago when Wi-Fi and
cellular seemed really far out for us
but in listening to users and listening
to developers they have higher
expectations for a SmartWatch they want
the watch to be able to do stuff on its
own and so with Android wear two dotto
we're introducing the concept of
untethered experiences where the watch
can talk to the cloud your cloud over
cellular and Wi-Fi and of course
bluetooth to the handset is still great
for many things it's about adding and
evolving the platform second so we call
this concept stand away so a second
Android wear has been about personal
expressions in the beginning we have
over 100 physical designs that you can
buy and we have over 4,000 watch faces
on the Play Store and so when it comes
to watch faces we really believe that
you should be able to choose what you
want to be your watch face but we want
more than that and users wanted more
than that they want utility in personal
expression and so we're evolving the
watch face with Android wear 2.0 to put
glanceable information and action right
on your watch face so this is the new
Android wear to watch faces an Android
wear is always been great at quick
replies about messages that are coming
your way from people that
care about but we heard from people that
they wanted a lot more than that they
wanted conversations they wanted to be
able to express themselves in a
multitude of ways and have those
conversations live on over there wash
over the course of it today so we call
this messaging making messaging great
and we're going to talk about that as
well
and finally Android wear launched with
activity tracking google fit does a
great job of keeping track if you're
walking you're running you're biking in
the background but we heard from people
and from developers that they wanted to
do more than that they wanted activity
tracking with insight and so with this
example this a thing that I've done this
morning which is nervously eat a little
too much breakfast whoops and a fitness
app can say well you know you did that
and you can get back on track towards
your fitness goals by doing the
following so this is helping users with
insight that's meaningful so we talked
about this as building great Fitness
experiences for Android wear and
together these are Android wear 2.0 so
we're launching a Developer Preview you
want your your feedback and we're going
to go into detail on all of these topics
so fitness messaging the watchface
standalone apps and we've got a new user
interface for both the system UI and
apps to tie it all together and so to
start we're going to give a tour of that
new user interface and let's roll the
video please so here I am I'm starting
out on my watch face and this is an
Android wear one gato style watch face
it's got the time it's got the date but
not a lot else that helps me get through
my day so with a simple left-to-right
swipe on my watch face a sideways swipe
I'm going to zoom out to the watch face
ticker any second now
here we go so just like that I'm zoomed
out to the watch face picker and if I
keep sliding to the to the left I'm
actually on my next watch face and I've
selected element's analog the annal bits
analog is a watch face that we built to
show off the capabilities of the new
watch face at API so I've already
customized it with four different things
that help me and let's say I wanted to
change one of these I wanted to change
this calorie tracker over to something
else so I'm just going to do a sideways
swipe tap on the gear icon at the bottom
and I'm editing the settings for this
watch face so I tap on complications the
left-hand dial and wipes um is a partner
that we've worked with and they help me
track things like how much water I've
drunk through the day
so let's tap on that and set that as my
complication so with a few swipes and
taps I've made my watch face more my own
and it looks like I'm a little behind on
drinking water and I'll get to that as
soon as I get off the stage so that's
the watch base we've built but what can
third parties do so let's let's check
out a third party watch face so again a
left sideways swipe gets me over to my
next watch face and here's Ranger from
Zoo handin and Rangers got a very unique
aesthetic so handin is really good at
making rangers sing on its own and so we
wanted to give watch face developers the
power to style these bits of data that
we call complications exactly they way
the way they want to so this your
Hannah's got its own color scheme its
own typeface and as a user I can also
customize the watch face to have
different complications on different
watch faces to suit different aspects of
what I need for my watch and Dan's going
to tell us a lot more about this so now
let's go check out how to add other
favorite watch faces to my watch
so I swipe over to the right and I
browse my watch face drawer and so I
just tap on elements Digital here and
I've added it to my favorites so cool
I've got four favorite watch faces but
you know this one dotto style one this
one that doesn't have actionable
information on it I'm going to get rid
of it so I have to do is toss it up it's
gone so elements is is my watch face now
I want to cover another important aspect
of Android wear 2.0 which is
a basic navigational concept of how to
get the user back to the watch face and
so for anywhere on Android wear all you
have to do is hit the hardware button on
the side of the device so let's say I
scroll to the bottom of my watch face
picker here and nothing's really
resonating for me so I decide to go back
I hit the hardware button on the side
and I'll go back to my list of favorites
and I hit the hardware button on the
side one more time and I'll be back at
the watch face so hardware button equals
back and now let's check out quick
settings so quick settings is the place
where you can quickly get your watch to
do what you want it to do kind of at the
system level so all you have to do is
drag down from the top of the watch and
we've made quick settings a lot more
compact and put all the actions that you
want right in one place and we've
especially gone deep on brightness
controls so if you tap on the little
brightness control here on the left you
get up-and-down paddles and as you start
interacting with them we give you a live
preview of what that brightness control
is going to do to your currently
selected watch face it's a and it's it's
pretty gratifying in person so hit the
hardware button to go back and I'll hit
the hardware button to go back again and
I'm back on the watch face so let's
check out app launching that's something
we also wanted to make better in Android
wear 2.0 so from the watch face again I
hit the hardware button and that will
open the app launcher and let's uh let's
we'll go back at the hitting the
hardware button again and get it go into
it again and you can see that it
actually comes out from where the
hardware button is on the side of the
device and has this really nice circular
reveal and of course the app launcher
itself takes advantage of the fact that
it's on a circular watch and it weighs
itself out accordingly and we've made it
managed to make the app launcher have
more icons on it and you can tap
anywhere to want launch an app so here I
scroll down to Strava and I can tap it
and it zooms into Strava and one one
done when I'm done recording my hike or
my ride I can hit the hardware button to
go back and I'm back in the launcher and
I hit the hardware button to go back one
more time and I'm back on the watch face
and let's say oh you know I want to app
launch Strava again so how could I do
that I just go into the app launcher and
strawbe is right at the top so we keep
track of the apps that the user launches
the most and put them right at the top
the launcher okay so let's get into the
bread and butter of Android wear which
is notifications and especially
messaging from people that you care
about so if my watch was in its
always-on mode
telling me the time and showing me the
data in my complications let's say I got
a message from a colleague well with
what that experience be like so here's
the ohi's on mode and I'm going to get a
message from crystal so crystals message
takes over my watch face in ambient mode
for a few seconds and if I don't
interact with it it goes away and then
later you know maybe when I'm done
talking to all of you I would wake up
the watch face and crystals avatar and
the app that she sent that message from
would come up and visit the watch face
and now if I scroll up her avatar will
re-enter on top of the the notification
card for this conversation
so yeah let's let's reply to crystal
here so I've got this conversational
detailed view on that on the
notification if I tap on reply I can do
voice reply emoji smart reply but let's
go use the QWERTY keyboard and with a
few taps P & R gets me the word I want
pretty G gets me good s gets me so and
it's predicted far and so with like four
or five taps I've got the sentence I
want and I'm done
and with the new notification API and
Android wear my message has been
appended to the conversation and
crystals already replied to keep this
conversation long-lived and Dan's going
to talk a lot more about that so I'll
hit the hardware button to go back I'm
back in the card stream and now I can
scroll and check out the rest of my
notifications so here's one from
Alexandre and then here's one from
google fit and you can see is as I'm
scrolling I'm getting a scrollbar on the
side with a thumb that tells me exactly
where I am in the card stream helps me
orient myself tells me how many
notifications I have so I'll hit the
hardware button to go back get taken
right back to the watch face and that's
the tour of the the new system UI well
let's go back to the slides and check
out how this relates to app patterns
so material design for apps is something
we're introducing with Android wear 2.0
and we're really excited what this will
do for app developers so with Android
wear one dotto we had the concept of
users navigating a relatively big
two-dimensional space users could scroll
down they could scroll up they could
scroll left they could scroll right that
had a lot of power but we found that
just a little too often users would get
a little confused where should I go next
to get more content to get more action
so we've doubled down on the concept of
a vertical layout where users start out
anchored at the top so they always know
exactly where to go to get more its to
scroll down and this is reinforced of
course in the system UI where you start
on the watch face and scroll down for
notifications and you start in the app
launcher and you scroll down through
your apps so we think that's consistency
from system UI all the way through apps
will really help users navigate Android
wear even more quickly and get the most
out of your app so look at this in a
little more detail we've got these
classic isomorphic drawings that we in
the material design team love to make so
your app is is mostly this content view
the main piece of information or action
that your app is responsible for and
what you can do if you need to add
actions that the user needs to take you
can add a wearable action George at the
bottom and when the user reaches the
bottom of the content view or changes
scroll directions this this component
can peek into view and if you have a
more complicated app that has you know
multiple views that are necessary to
render in it you can add a wearable
navigation drawer to the top of the app
that peeks in when the user reaches the
top so the main benefit of this is that
the relatively small screen of a wear
device is maximized by having the
content be front and center and then
actions are available just off the
screen and navigation is available just
off the screen so let's let's take a
look at this from the end users point of
view so here's a user scrolling down in
an app and they reach the bottom and the
drawer is right there for them to grab
and we'll loop that around again so they
scroll down they either change scroll
direction or reach the bottom and the
drawer is there and there's a primary
action there that they could
tapped if that's what they wanted but if
they want to explore more actions they
just drag that drawer up let's look at
the navigation drawer and we'll wait for
this animation come around one more time
and so here's the user at the top of
their app and they drag down for their
navigation drawer and they can change
views watch this one more time for
clarity they dragged down there in their
navigation drawer and they can change
views so now that we've talked about
layout and functionality let's talk a
little bit about aesthetics Android wear
wand auto apps have generally taken
their design cues from handset which
generally means bright white apps and we
think this is this is great but we want
to make something that's really specific
for wearables and that means that we're
recommending that all apps develop a
dark app a dark color palette there's
two big benefits for this one is that
OLED displays are actually very powerful
on Android wear devices and they're very
popular and OLED displays consume a lot
less power when they're set to emit less
light so if you choose if you have a
light a white light less light less
light emitting you'll you'll save the
user power the other main benefit is
social appropriateness there's just a
lot of contexts where emitting a lot of
light is just not good design so if
you're watching a movie in the evening
or out at a restaurant at night you
don't want your watch thrown off a lot
of white and we'll make this easy for
you developers to adopt all you have to
do is tell us your primary app color and
we can compute all the other shades that
you need for your app and finally oh and
this works for within like the the
purpley apps out there it works for all
the apps on the rainbow and yet don't
forget that Android wear apps are real
apps they have access to the entire
Android SDK and Android wear apps are
even more powerful than the actual
normal Android apps and that they have
always-on capabilities so what this
means that if I've got visitors from out
of town that like their Marmite and I go
to the store to shop for it and I bring
that up on my wrist and I'm wandering
the store and my purse or term memory is
not great so I'll just forget what I was
shopping for but my watch goes into
always
mode and it reminds me what I'm shopping
for great for to-do lists it's great for
fitness apps definitely take advantage
of always on and to talk oh yes to wrap
up on system UI and material design
we've got a new watch face picker a new
app launcher a new notification stream a
new navigation model material design
patterns for wearables we really want to
hear what you have to think about all
this and I'm going to turn it over to
Dan for more about standalone apps
thanks Brett all right so stay little
naps as Brett mentioned before we think
that the independence of the watch is
going to be really key for experiences
in Android wear 2.0 so that's going to
let a user slap on their watch and go
for a run they can count their steps
they can track their progress and they
can actually stream music all without
having to bring their phone so they get
faster times and this is also really
going to dramatically change the
developer experience that you guys have
and that's because we're going to be
able to bring a more Android development
experience when it comes to cloud and
data authentication notifications and
distribution so for cloud and data and
here's how it used to work if the watch
needed some data from the cloud it would
start with a request to the phone then
the phone would get the data from the
cloud download it put it back in the
wearable data layer take it over to the
watch and the watch could then display
it well with standalone apps you'll be
able to use the network connection
directly on the watch so you'll be able
to use HTTP TCP UDP whatever you want
and you don't have to worry about
whether that device has a Wi-Fi or
cellular radio because no matter what
we'll still be able to if we need to
proxy the network from the phone and so
you'll be able to take all the
development patterns that you know from
Android phone a tablet development use
all the libraries like volley and you'll
maybe even be able to use some reuse
some code from your phone and tablet
apps right on the watch and of course
you'll still want to use the best
practices you've learned from writing
phone and tablet apps and I just want to
call attention to two one is don't grab
data that you're not going to use one
mistake we see sometimes is people
get images that are way larger than
their screen well there's no sense in
downloading data you're not going to
show the user so just in general avoid
that it'll hurt latency and battery life
also I want to talk a little bit about
doze and doze light so those are coming
to Android wear 2.0 they're important
ways that we manage the battery life of
the of the watch and so you definitely
want to play nice with those they are
responsible for minimizing the wake up
which are really battery impacting and
so you can schedule jobs using job
scheduler this is our recommended
practice you'll be able to schedule
those jobs in the basis of time whether
or not you need a connection to the
internet or whether or not you need
power for long running tasks or things
like that and so this is really great
already for things like downloading the
weather from the cloud and showing out
to users but if you're wanting to do
more
maybe privacy sensitive things maybe a
messaging application then you want to
worry about a fennec ation and so with
Android wear 2.0 for standalone apps
view watch will be managing its own
authentication we have several patterns
available that you can look at there's a
there's patterns that all the patterns
balance developer time user experience
and flexibility in terms of what
platforms running on the phone I'm not
going to go into all the nitty-gritty
there's tons more information available
at the standalone talk later today and
online so do check that out so on to
notifications so notifications have
always been the lifeblood of Android
wear and the magic of the experience
comes from them being the same
experience in terms of the notification
between the wear the watch and the phone
so if you get a notification from an app
it appears in both places if you take
action on either of those places it's
reflected in the other and of course if
you dismiss from one place it's gone
from the other as well and that has been
achieved in the past with notification
bridging and that's still definitely an
option for you but now that you've got
the network you may want to manage
notifications directly from your
standalone app and so you can by the way
use firebase Cloud messaging for
Molina's GCM Google Cloud messaging to
actually have the server wake up your
watch and then the watch can notify the
user
so now that you're able to generate
notifications directly from the watch
you may want to shut off notification
bridging and there's an API for that and
also we have some patterns on helping to
keep that replicated experience so that
interactions seem to happen in both
places so now onto distribution so this
is a big change and we're 2.0 it used to
be that to ship watch software you would
embed it in your phone apk and it's been
unnecessary unnecessary stuff for users
to download and of course it affects
this space and now an Android wear 2.0
watches can download install apps
directly from the Play Store and not
only does this fix the problem of
growing phone apks but it also makes it
possible to ship apps to watches without
having to worry about what operating
system is running on the paired phone so
you'll be able to reach a lot more users
and so yeah it's great news
so stand alone is a really big change
not only does it let users interact with
their devices in more ways but it's also
a huge change for developers so now you
can just do so much more on the on the
watch itself and we're really excited to
see what happens now with you guys
taking advantage of this alright on to
watch faces now watch faces have always
been a really key part of Android wear
from the very start we had always on
watch faces so the watch is always ready
to tell you the time and you developers
really ran with our watch face api's and
that there are thousands of watch faces
available on the Play Store that let
users really customize how their watches
look super important considering this is
something we wear so and then the
interactivity applies that API is that
we added last year really made the watch
face a tool so it's not just for showing
data it's for interaction as well and so
we wanted to take that and bring it to
all the apps that run on Android wear so
imagine if all the apps could
participate in on the watch face show
information and then generate those user
experiences so we're adding this
complications API and Android web 2.0 so
the term complications comes from
traditional watch making and it refers
to any informative element on the watch
face that's not just telling you the
time so on traditional watch faces this
could tell you the day of the week or
the day of the month when your alarms
gonna go off or maybe that phases of the
Moon yeah if you're a werewolf hunter
very important so and we think for
smartwatches they should be able to do
Smart Watch II things these
complications so they should tell you
Smart Watch types of data like how many
steps you've taken how many calories
maybe you've eaten if you have incoming
messages and of course they should also
react to touch so touching that
notification should drive me to an
experience where I can then act on it
and so the complications API is a API
for data providers and watch face
developers and it lets the two work
together to provide both form and
function to the watch face and there's
no need for them to know anything about
each other in advance
no biz dev deals to sign for data or
anything like that
so for data providers this is a big deal
it's going to let you get your
interactions and your data on a lot more
watch faces in fact you'll be able to
have your data rendered by top fashion
brands and other experts and making
beautiful watch faces and of course you
can drive users back to your
applications by when they touch the
complications because you assigned a
pending intent that gets sent when they
do that so life's tum has been able to
add some complications to watch faces
that can do things like track breath so
drink some water let him know how he's
doing with his goals so and you get back
to life some to blog all that and watch
face developers are going to be able to
concentrate on making really beautiful
watch faces and they don't have to
acquire a ton of experience with fitness
or messaging in order to provide that
functionality users so here's how it
works
Android wear acts as a broker so the to
never really talk directly to each other
it starts when it decides it needs to
have a complication drawn it sends an
update request to the data provider the
data provider gets that request it fills
out this complication data object and
sends it back to Android wear engine
where then forwards it on to the watch
face which then can draw it with
whatever ascetic it wants because it
owns the entire drawing part of that and
the way they coordinate on the general
idea of the presentation is through the
type that's on that complication data so
there's lots of different types for lots
of different use cases I'm going to walk
through just a few of them so if you
want to show the day of the month how
many messages you have or maybe the
temperature outside you can use the
short text type this is just a little
bit of text and maybe an icon if you can
go even simpler then maybe you want to
use the icon type this just shows a
picture so for example it might tell me
it's signing outside if I see a Sun and
of course since these complications
receive touches they can also be used as
just icons so the user knows it's like a
launcher back to your app and there's
also a range value type think of this as
a value between a minimum and a maximum
maybe a percentage how many of my daily
calories I've eaten or how much gas is
in my car
and there's lots more examples you can
read about them online or you can talk
to us in the sandbox later and so if
you're a data provider you want to be
thinking about all the different kinds
of data that you have that you can show
users and you want to think about what
action they can take when I touch those
complications and if your watch face
developer you want to think about how
you can make these things really
beautiful for users so I want to show
you a few examples from our partner us
to they've taken here there's three
examples in this first one they've taken
a existing watch face so they already
shipped and they've upgraded it to use
complications you can see they've added
into the left on the right there they
found some space to their existing face
and add them and and it fits right in
it's I think it's pretty nice this next
example is a new watch face that they've
written to take advantage take advantage
of the complication API and you can see
that it makes obvious reference to
mechanical watch faces and of course it
has that classic looking dial
complication and so if you want that
classic look on your watch this is a
great choice this last one is takes a
lot more creative Liberty with data
visualization it's using the background
and the color of the background the
texture and color of the background to
render some data so if they were to hook
this up to a ranged value type then
maybe as it gets warmer outside it'd get
the watch face gets redder our watches
were red yeah yes our watches were red
all day yesterday and I think my face
may have gotten redder and this on to
alright so watch face is 2.0 it's a it's
a nice it's a huge change actually to
the way watch faces are going to be as
user experiences and as developer
experiences on Android wear 2.0 I think
it's really going to unlock some great
form and function for the watch face
alright let's get on to messaging so
Android wear has always been a great
platform for receiving and replying to
messages we wanted to make that
experience last longer and make it more
conversational so you could get back to
messages
as you go through your day so we started
by looking at what we have today and I
just want to walk you through what we
saw so here I've got a message from my
friend Jim we've been chatting about my
friend Charles's new dog and he's asking
me what's the name so I'm going to swipe
over I'm going to touch reply and I'll
speak my reply the dog's name is
Brooklyn which is a pretty cute name for
a dog and then I get this nice checkmark
that tells me that the message has been
sent and I feel great and then I realize
actually my friend with the dog Charles
is looking for a dog walker so I'd like
to actually tell Jim hey maybe this is
maybe this would be awesome for you and
so I go back to the stream and look for
that card and it's gone and this is
actually because the messaging app has
marked the conversation as red because
I've acted on it and it's withdrawn the
notification so now I kind of have the
hassle to get back to my friend so let's
see what we've done down in Android
we're 2.0 you can see that there's a big
visual change and we've added I just
want to draw your eye to this icon at
the bottom that's actually a an inline
action in this case it's a reply action
and it's super easy for users to
discover it's right there on the card
and when they touch that they're going
to get to this new remote input UI as
you can see we're offering choices now
on on the input method that you pick to
to talk or to respond and voice is still
there in case you're on the go or don't
have your hands available but we also
now have touch based input methods and
it's an entire input method framework so
our create our partner touch panel has
made this a nice new watch face and
you'll be able to make watch faces and
when users download install them they'll
be ready to go for when users want to
type and so now I've sent my message I
see it appear right on the card and the
card doesn't go away and this happens
for two reasons the first is we're using
the new messaging style for
notifications that's been out of android
and is also on Android wear 2.0 and
that's going to allow the UI to take
that reply and just put it right in the
card it knows where to put it because of
the clearly defined semantics of the
message and also we're asking developers
not to retract messages until they know
that the user has dismissed them and we
think that that's going to create
longer running conversational experience
and in general notifications on where
2.0 are going to be a lot more like they
are on phones and tablets on a phone or
a tablet you have this expectation that
if you swipe down on the shade and you
touch a notification you get to an
experience that you know for the app
that submitted the notification you get
to a part of that app where you can then
act on whatever you've seen and we want
that to work the same for Android wear
so we're asking developers to set the
content intent to drive users back to
your carefully crafted experiences now
if you're using notification bridging
what happens so in this case there isn't
an app on the watch but we have a
solution so we decided to make a great
expanded notification experience and
this works for all notifications when
you touch a notification you launch into
it and it kind of stands in for the app
and for messaging especially we're able
to present an experience that's a lot
like the best of what we see in
messaging apps so because of all the
data you add in your messaging style for
that notification we can show you
conversation history your messages come
in in the right place and we've also
added a smart replies API that lets
Android wear insert contextually
appropriate possible replies then it
does that using the machine learning
model right on the device and of course
as you use your conversational apps more
they show up on the launcher in the
recent section so they're easy to get
back to and the new complications will
allow users to add shortcuts to
conversations and people they care about
right on the watch face so my partner is
just one touch away so messaging just
got a lot more conversational
we now have inline actions that are
easily discoverable and easy to use we
have inline replies so messages show up
right in the right place we have
constant intents that launch apps and of
course expanded notifications that stand
in for those apps when they're not there
the app launch here is much faster to
get back to conversational apps and save
conversations you can save your
conversations and put them right on the
watch face you can get back to them
easily all right back over to Bret for
hearing about the fit platform on
Android wear thank you
so as we've heard from users and
developers users want more in terms of
want more from their wearable
experiences in terms of helping them
reach their fitness goals and developers
wanted more out of the fit platform in
terms of being able to help users so
we've heard that feedback and we have a
bunch of stuff to talk about in the
fitness platform so we're doing three
things in 2016
real-time data update notifications so
that you can drive contextual
notifications and experiences for users
real-time gym activity recognition so
that untapped experience of being in the
gym can get a lot better with the with a
wearable fitness app and the one I'm
really excited about a really magical
one which is real-time walking running
and bicycling recognition so let's talk
about these so real thing real-time data
update notifications that allow you to
set a pending intent to get updates on
any of these data types in the fitt
platform concretely it means that an app
like life some can look for when i've
stopped a a fitness activity like the
the walk i went on this morning and it
can say hey you should have a glass of
water based on the length of that
activity or if i did a long bike ride it
might say you should have two or three
glasses of water and call back to our
earlier experience if i've overeat in a
little bit and log that in an app
another app can look at that and say hey
to get back on track maybe eat a little
less or do a little bit of a workout so
these kind of real-time contextually
driven notifications are just a lot more
possible in Android wear 2.0 and we're
looking forward to what you do with them
second is that we're working on an API
for launching later this year that
actually recognizes the actions that
people are doing in the gym so that
means that bicep curl deadlifts push-ups
squats can all be recognized in real
time and that you can you can build
Fitness experiences around that for for
people's gym time third is recognizing
outdoor activities such as
walking running and cycling this means
that the user just by wearing their
wearable and starting a run the app that
they want to launch when they start back
activity will just launch and support
that activity so for me that's Strava
and I can't wait to actually use this so
that I don't have to like you know
fiddle with my watch to launch an app to
support my run we're really excited
about this one so that's all the fitness
stuff for Android wear 2.0 and then just
in summary we've made a lot of
improvements across the entire platform
Fitness messaging the watchface
standalone apps and a new user interface
and app patterns to tie it all together
so but this is a Developer Preview so we
want to hear from you so come talk to us
come talk to Dan and I after the talk
go to G doc GGO slash water preview and
you can download developer guidelines
designer guidelines the new emulator and
system images for a couple of watches
yeah and this developer preview is
really it's not just about us telling
you what to do we also want to hear what
you need from us so please do let start
the conversation real soon thank you
everyone
ah